all right since we've been away and we
have no interview scheduled for today
we're gonna take a few phone calls six
one seven eight three zero
4750 is the number we'll start with our
caller from five one six go ahead five
one six what's on your mind okay I just
wanted to call in and voice concern
about the issue of restaurants for
people refusing service to people that
they don't agree with it's okay I know
that I wouldn't want to serve somebody
with odious opinions that I've disagreed
with but I can see this going in a
direction that that gets very unpleasant
for example things more important than
where you have dinner things like you
know somebody helping you with a
broken-down car
con Edison giving you utility service at
what point should we draw the line and
say that there are certain things that
you can't discriminate against just want
to hear your thoughts okay so I mean
you're bringing up a very specific
you're thinking about this the right way
which is where where is a line cross so
let's first talk about where the line
would be crossed today right and then we
can talk about what you think should be
changed about that you can't refuse
service to people on a variety of
different basis right you can't refuse
service to people on the basis of the
religion or nationality or gender in
some states you can refuse service on
the basis of their perceived a real
sexual orientation depends on the state
depends how the law is now you talked
about con Edison con Edison of course is
a utility provider utility providers
typically are not the same as a
mom-and-pop restaurant or your local
deli and they you had they have to
provide service period right in other
words they are the public utility of
record they are the contracted supplier
of a gas or electricity depending on
where you live so that is not actually
something that they would be able to do
so I think it's important for us to
think about when we think about what's
okay and what's not okay
we should really understand what the law
says so con Edison wouldn't be able to
say we're not going to give electricity
to Trump supporters they are legally
bound to provide
Electrical service to everybody period
they're not allowed to make that type of
decision a restaurant right restaurant
might be a can't refuse people the basis
of religion but they can on the basis of
political beliefs right now are you
saying that political beliefs should be
a protected class I wouldn't go so far
because I know that although I I
disagree with the person who refused to
bake the cake for the gay couple I I do
think that there's a line I know that I
wouldn't want to be forced to bake the
cake for let's say a Nazi or a neo-nazi
but you get how it's different right
like let's hold that let's make sure we
understand the difference if if you're
in a state where sexual orientation is a
protected class it would be against the
law to refuse service on the basis of
sexual orientation white supremacist
beliefs are not indicative of membership
in any protected class so I do what you
understand why the analogy is not an
accurate one right right so you're
you're drawing a line between what what
classes and what the dates are protected
by the law and right now if what you're
saying is that you want to change that
if you're saying you want political
beliefs protected as you want sexual
orientation protected or maybe you don't
want either protected that's the debate
to have beyond that it's just an opinion
thing right like you think it will get
ugly if restaurants say people with
certain political beliefs not welcomed
that's certainly a position you can have
I would argue that the reason that
that's happening is because of really
ugly things that are being done by this
administration and it's just a debate
people can sort of have right I don't
think that the restaurant issue is where
it might get ugly I think that if it
starts extending to more important
services maybe not as extreme an example
as con Edison supplying electric
electricity yeah but other important
things that people rely on in their
daily lives
well give me an example give so if it's
not a restaurant but not electric
where are you concerned what would be a
concerning example let's say your car
breaks down and you go to the local guy
to fix it you need to let's say you're
out of state and you're driving home yep
he's a trump sticker says I don't want
to serve you you think that should be
illegal I don't know if it should be
illegal but that's definitely where the
issue is gonna get uglier then you know
the restaurant their point out FairPoint
no that's true you're definitely talking
about something much closer to people's
livelihood particularly in this heat
breaking down in this heat could be bad
let me think about that more but I
really appreciate you bringing bringing
it up sure thanks all right thank you so
much